[Musique]
chartaa dernière fois qu'on s'est
rencontrés c'était pour la finale de
district de tenter un way est ce qu'il
ya une vie après dix trucs tellement ben
oui une vie plus libre une vie remplie
de projets c'est super coach est aussi
occupée mais matt a été moins occupé je
passe comment ce que je veux dire parce
qu'elle a la taille des remplit quand
scrutateurs la quantité texte à
apprendre bonjour puis quand on tournait
aussi folle être performant tout le
temps parce qu'on n'avait pas de grands
prison pour chaque saint ex mais oui
j'étais occupé mais j'ai du fun à faire
mes affaires à fin mai projet à voir mes
amis à
travailler sur mes affaires mais de plus
en plus ça c'est formidable
les proches leur passé de 5,8 ensemble
tellement projet tout d'abord la pièce à
l'institut est co écrite avec votre
grotte ami françois chénier vous parlez
lada de bipolarité pourquoi avoir choisi
ce thème là moi j'ai toujours trouvé sur
le film vol au-dessus d'un nid de coucou
de milos forman et j'ai fait jamais sauf
à un vol au dessus d'un gros coup mais
comique drôle avec des situations très
pente où les gens se reconnaîtront se
reconnaîtront pas nécessairement mais
vont trouver leur compte dans ma tout
connaître quelqu'un qui souffre de telle
ou telle maladie notre but premier
c'était pas de rire de ces gens là au
contraire cédé met en valeur mais il
sait ce qu'on s'est informé auprès de
certaines personnes et des traits des
professionnels de la santé évidemment
pour être exact sur certains thèmes
j'ai eu une petite émotion lors de la
répétition de l'institut parce que vous
étiez à côté de françois chesnais votre
grand ami henri chassé aussi votre
mentor c'était vraiment de michel
charrette legault de gagne ben ouais je
pense que c'est un sam définit bien
j'étais un gars de gang henry c'était
celle que j'ai connue collège ses 2 go
team a mis au monde ses deux pieds
changé ma vie c'est mon mentor il manque
il m'a donné confiance en moi et me dit
oui tu peux faire ce métier là donc il
me coachait pour rentrer aux
conservateurs après ça il m'a coaché
pour mes options pour les options du
quat'sous c'est lui qui m'a emmené voir
le vraiment de la création qui m'est
rentré dedans j'ai fait un jour je vais
jouer cette pièce là trente ans plus
tard avec le temps qu'on a plutôt sur
l'expérience je fête et harry pour le
foetus est fait ok tu joues quoi je veux
pas que tu joues à sa mise en scène
comme à l'époque c'est comme bouclé la
boucle un petit peu et avec le vraiment
on va faire de la tournée à l'hiver 2024
à québec et à pression s'en va jouer à
paris juillet 2023 ouais c'est ça vous
revenez de paris telle est la 4 jours on
est allé rencontrer les gentils terre du
soleil ariane mnouchkine qui a vu la
captation de ces pièces-là gel des
contacts et j'ai dit je vais aller jouer
ce show-là paris michel tremblay doit
rayonner partout dans le monde comme il
fait déjà il ya pas besoin de moi pour
rayonner partout dans le monde et ariane
chine est une femme de michel aulas
vient de monter justement les belles
soeurs et on est super long on a vu leur
spectacle qui est là ça a été c'est un
rêve de ti cul moi je me suis encore de
son film sur maria qui a changé ma vie
juste un film c'est un grand film et
tout les choucas le monte c'est madame
théâtre à travers le monde alors tout ce
qui reste à faire c'est de le montage
financier alors s'il ya des chaque côté
des restes investir dans cette
magnifique projet on serait banale mais
c'est sûr que ça va se faire autre
projet pour vous vous allez faire de la
radio cet été avec jessica barc
absolument ça fait à peu près n'impose
pas de
l'or ce
matin l'action saint gobain gagne comme
tu disais tantôt james est entouré puis
je travaille souvent avec mes amis ou
des gens que je trouve que j'ai beaucoup
de respect pour les gens qui ont du
talent plein incompétent pour moi seule
course urbaine impressionnante côté ont
pu offrir du support à tout le monde ça
qu'on veut mais quand les gens veulent
pas l'utiliser là le monsieur charette
qui est devant moi est vraiment loin du
michel charrette de ya 30 vies
gracieuseté de vos amis patrice godin
qui vous aider dans votre remise en
forme
mais la question qui m'intéressait quel
était le moment le déclic décisif s'est
éteint mardi soir à jeudi matin un
moment décisif c'est que mon fils qui
joue dans rien à vendre chez nous qu'il
ya quatre ans à l'époque puis j'en ai
48 je pense quelque chose comme ça que
je le vaux corinne henry joue à qui je
fais ok dans deux trois ans doit être
capable d'aller jouer que dans une rue
ou acquis de faire du vélo de montagne
études juives est non seulement la bonne
chère pogab à très satisfaits du clic
l'eau j'avais un genre de quatre mois
devant moi j'ai dit à ma blonde du 10
juin l'homme on a dit löw lors ça fait
15 ans tu mens pas de ton propre à moi
règle ou pas de mougins piste éclairée
jeu parfait 12h01 quatre mois devant un
moyen de gamme je m'occupe de tout je
m'occupe des enfants je m'occupe de la
maison des jeunes ce temps-là tu
appartiens méprendre faisant quelque
chose de positif jeu parfait et je suis
parti avec ce je me sens entouré gros
soutien psychologique professionnels de
la santé au niveau de la psychologie
j'ai pas le choix tu peux pas faire
surtout que c'est impossible entraîneur
physiothérapeute nutritionnelle j'ai
tout mais j'ai fait de la bonne façon et
tranquillement je les fait j'ai plafonné
combien de fois je t'avais dans le
bureau d'un psychologue et j'ai juste
brouilly fin jeudi arriverez pas je
serais pas capable c'est trop gros si si
c'est ça ok mais reprend le même chemin
que tu veux faire comme que tu fais et
puis retombant même place a dit
abandonne pour aj et cette fois là j'ai
jamais abandonné
[Musique]
comme si ce n'était pas assez parlons de
votre dernier projet celui de 2024 votre
premier spectacle en solo et ça
avancerait rencontre semblait bien
écosse 3 de même chose ça va être une
histoire c'est un faux faut juste pas de
france c'est un one man show que je
deviens pas humoriste c'est pas ça du
tout c'est un one man show comme
guylaine tremblay le faible comme anne
élisabeth bossé il le fait comme
emmanuel bilodeau le fait oui ça va être
principalement de l'humour c'est ce que
j'aime faire dans ripd sommet si j'ai
des moments d'émotion aussi des moments
plus centre de sensibilité je voyais
aller jeter un acte ajoie les
interpréter genre souvent à le faire
j'ai hâte de voir ce chercheur remercie
infiniment merci d'entrevue très gentil